おっ
えっ
[音楽]
ていました
本日は肇社長です
入ってあげる地下の家の改造が終わりましたーーー
ああああああ
[笑い]
家の構造説明しますとまずさっき見たこの上にあの1階玄関の方であるんですよ
ここは一回になっておりましてそんなにまあ撮影宮田ばお風呂とかシャワーとかはある
んですけども
2回その上に編集ベルト金具カードとか遊んですき家が張ってで結構普通に正確てるん
じゃ全然を広すぎて聞くにユーチューバーなきゃとてもいいのかなと思ってるんだけど
も
さらにこの物件地下にガレージがついています前に今までのヶ月はこんな感じでしたら
どうぞ
[音楽]
きた分まあな口書きたくなりますと思いますが youtube で物をたくさんで
ものになってしまうまさにがですあとでエアコンが付いてないんですよねエアコンも
ついてないタイプ動画のといいますと
必然的にものにいるんですよまさしく彼氏としてもう一つ一か月になる要素がありまし
て照明がめっちゃ暗かったんですよ非常に暗い電欠聞いてもこんな感じでくらいですよ
ね
ガレッジですマジでもう何度通り金ちょこんときたね御目標になっていたんですけども
な
このだ辛い改造を果たしましてどうすればがねぇ所ちゃんと使えるのかなっていうの
大家さんとも色々お話しして改造することに成功しました
ではた所属見ていきましたいきます
バックラインはいもうねくらいんですよやっぱり地下光も範囲ないしていただけでまず
は強化された部屋の明るさを見てみましょう
どうぞ
これはまだ第1弾だ平カイザー
ある8敗もうスタジオみたいになっちゃいますよこれはご覧くださいかつてこんなに来
なかった照明は天井打ち腰
な中の蛍光灯打ち込むことによってこんなに明るくなりました
でヤバくないすか動画とる人間のシェパ一番気にするとかやっぱないっていうとか光だ
と思うんですけども
こんなに明るければどこで撮っても分かる
とれねーもう動画を取りには申し分ない当たる風になったのかなと思います
そしてさらに入っ
ああああああ
結局暑いといった気ないんで栄光つけることによって夏も冬も快適にこの部屋で動画
撮影ができるんじゃないかなと思います
じゃあまずで懲戒としましたそしてズー
光ってに砂が光ってるんだけど
アイス移動モーセにあった
リーダーことにそので永水を使うような激しい動画をですね
したらもコンクリートなんで思う存分をぶちまけていろいろどうが取れるような気がし
ております
もうほぼねーすべて状態までも今で3月ますそして最後にみなさんに見せたいなら
こちら
兄弟プレイ
[拍手]
ん俺が何を意味してるかわかるから胸この巨大スクリーンがあることによって
壮大だでねま村上たらべったりコーラ a の
また youtube の動画を乾燥ができるという実感に映画館をつくってしまった
と言っても過言ではないとの桜キター
外れ社長2
イニングというところまで大改造せして参りました
いやもう完全にものではなくね動画スタート生活空間になってしまいました
ひょっとすれば国が撮影の命名になるような気もしてるんでちょっとこんな撮影の
スケジュールは分からないんですけどなんかいずも型って夢と違うなと思ったら力と
思ってくれていいと思います
[音楽]
たてねー私金子んよカメラ回ってるって事は
があるんですねどっちじゃないかまあドッキリじゃないということはお前にとっておき
のプレゼントができればですからプレプレゼンっえっああーっもうまえええ
ちょいああああああっ
うつに住みたいかでまぁ平均それはもう進めることが住みたいですよ
まあですか
うーん芸
a 的ですごいスクリーンが彼はお湯っこを地球に落下する
早くも付いているそう水道ある国もある
で僕はやたでねーああ
が今日皿いい終わらな
n ame
[音楽]
car
ううううううっ
ni
me
あっはぁ